do you ever wear a pair of sweatpants do
you own a pair of sweatpants they have
rhinestones on them and I wear high
heels with them they do and you
do oh actually of course we all have our
comfort zone you know it's like I don't
wear sweatpants so much as I but I have
my little comfy clothes my little
pajamas and you know a special drawer of
cozy clothes yeah just soft junk clothes
soft junk clothes that's exactly it CU
yeah of course nobody's days you know I
try you know for my husband when I'm
around the house I try to put on a
little makeup and you know in the days
I'm not even working I'll pull my hair
up in a scrunchie or or whatever but I
like to kind of you know I feel better
when I have all little makeup I never
know who's going to come to my door and
I'm not about to go looking like
somebody's mug shot what if Elvis came
to your door because I I think well if
Elvis came to my door I'd be looking for
Jesus right behind you I mean yeah
that's true today if Elvis came to your
door that would be weird but back in the
day is it true that Colonel Tom Parker
came to you about I will always love you
oh yeah and you had to again this is
where I think you know yourself so well
where you give yourself permission where
you know your boundaries of what can and
can't work for you and I think that
takes a lot of people a lifetime to
learn and sometimes still struggle with
it why did you decide to not allow them
to use the song was it because of the
ownership rights yes uh well I already
had a number one song on it that song
came out in 1972 I think that it came
out I know that album and uh Jolene and
I will always love you were on the same
album but anyway I had a number one song
and I will always love you and so I had
started my publishing company and that
was the my biggest copyright at that
time and because it had been number one
and so I was starting that for my my
family you know for whatever I would
leave behind so when they said I was
going to go down to record the song or
going to the session uh when Elis was
going to record it and the next morning
and Colonel Tom called me that afternoon
and said you know we don't record
anything with El unless we have the
publishing I said well you can't have
the publishing on that one he said well
we have to have at least half I said you
can't have half either I said he said
well then we can't record it and I was
heartbroken cuz it wasn't Elvis uh it
was Colonel Tom you know he made a lot
of decisions that Elvis didn't even know
about know about probably but anyhow so
I didn't let him have it and then
several years later of course Whitney
did it and I was so glad to keep the
publishing because I made a lot of money
off of that and you deserve I want Tom
to have had that money for him and his
family I agree but that went well and
but uh speaking of uh right after that I
thought I got to hear Elvis singing I'll
Always Love You
so I wrote a song called I dreamed about
Elvis and Elvis came to me in a dream
and it tells that whole story about him
saying well you know I wanted to sing a
song the one about true love that I Will
Always Love You song but the colonel
screwed that up anyway so the whole song
is called and so I said well you know
this is my dream could you sing it with
me now and so we record it and that's
one of my favorite songs on my Rockstar
album yeah so anyway a guy that sounds
just like Elvis you know did the the
voice and the talking and we had a
conversation so everything kind of makes
us a little circle Whitney had I will
always love you made it worldwide I mean
I love but I made that decision as a
businesswoman I was thinking you know
I'm starting out my life and it is the
music business so I was exercising the
business end of you know of the
[Music]
music
you